hey everybody and welcome to a revealing
wild ride with stevo not only are we
gonna learn some crazy stuff about a
legend of hip hop which too short is
we're also going to perhaps reveal me to
be getting pretty good at interviewing
people i think i did a good job on this
one man but let me tell you what does a
great job
the tushy ace from hellotushy.com
i'm telling you man i've always said
this is my favorite sponsor of the wild
ride podcast and that is not changing
man this new product comes with a remote
that just sticks to my wall when i get
ready to take a dump boom i hit seat
temperature so
that just warms up the seat so i'm nice
and comfy i take my dump and then when i
get done boom i blast the the bum
blaster oh my gosh it's just the most
luxurious bidet that you could possibly
get and it's got a front blaster for the
ladies too
so when i get done blasting my butt then
i hit dry boom and a little
butt dryer comes out
it's so comfy it's so luxurious the
holidays are coming up and you cannot
get a more luxurious gift
for the person person that you love yeah
so go to hellotischee.com
stevo to get 10 off your order and be
among the very first people to ever try
the tushy ace
man
it is
so awesome one more time
hellotushy.com
stevo for 10 off your order and so you
can be one of the very first people to
get a chance to try the tushy ace now
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen too short
yeah dude what's up what's up what's up
this is my co-host scott randolph what's
going on and up at the front we have the
gorgeous paul briskey nice to meet you
man how are you
got to tell on myself man i'm [ __ ]
later than [ __ ] dude how late are you
it's so uncomfortable for me to be going
somewhere where i'm late and it's just
like
all over my body it was physically just
uncomfortable i was filming a surf show
for kook of the day
and i did catch five waves but
we were supposed to start 50 minutes ago
this is an awful embarrassment it's so
unprofessional of me and i'm
so you're the cook of the day yeah i am
the coop
you're too late i'm on a carefree day
today so it's cool good epic yeah that's
good thank you okay so yeah dude i mean
where to begin dude like you got a
career that's gone for [ __ ] ever
yeah i don't i don't know where you
begin you just kind of you just kind of
exist you just yeah there was no
beginning there was no ending i i was
checking it out dude like uh
did
is it's your
career really began in earnest in 1983
around that time i started i first
started rapping in the year 1980 i first
heard rap in 79 yeah so a year later i'm
like i can do this and i just it was
just a little high school hobby
and right near the end of high school it
started like really growing
at that time like when did like the fat
boys come out at the same time 82 83
same time one dmc
run dmc was uh were they even that early
they were there um
you know crush groove the movie was a
big deal that was like 1984
right you know at that time curtis blow
was the big guy in the movie and
run dmc was you know the next upcoming
stars and llq emerged as but that's
still way later
yeah but you know but he he appeared in
that movie okay he was like a new guy
kicked in the door of his radio but
during that time all this is taking
place i'm famous
in the bay area yeah like i'm i'm not
making records i'm not assigned to a
label but i'm famous i'm doing parties
i'm making money i'm in high school and
i'm just like you know
i don't i'm not really getting the
opportunity of being on a major label
which i'm glad i wasn't because i had a
lot of time to
be
mediocre and learn you know sure by the
time i got to a major label i was a
seasoned veteran what was the label that
your first label was called 75 75 girls
records that was a local label and
the guy who owned his name was dean
hodges and he had somewhere along in
life he got the formula of how to be an
independent label so 75 girls is a
pimping reference i would imagine it is
a reference that he got from a johnny
guitar watson song i don't know the name
of the song i know we used to listen to
it and dean hodges really loved this one
line in the song
johnny guitar watson sings
like he was on a horse or a motorcycle
or something i don't i can't remember a
long time ago but he rides up and all in
one motion he kisses 75 girls at the
same time
and dean liked that so much he named his
label 75 girls records nice pretty good
wow it's that's an independent label
yeah now you
you recorded three albums on that label
they released three albums i recorded
two the third one
the third album was a homemade tape that
i used to just sit around making these
little homemade tapes with a mixer and a
turntable and turn some records over the
instrumental side and just record
songs that i wrote and
they found after i did the two albums
and you know we moved on it was like a
family environment
the next
venture that we did i did it with
dean hodges little brother and his first
cousin you know it was just oh that was
the
dangerous dangerous music yeah so we're
just off to the next it was still still
in the family but but you know um
i mean man you know
i could tell you things about those
years like things sure
so the albums that you were that you put
out with
75 girls are those the tapes that you're
selling in the park
two of them were literally in the studio
working in a really nice studio the one
is titled don't stop rapping sure
recorded out of stuff that's the very
first one yeah recorded a studio in
san francisco different fur and the next
one after that was called players same
thing we went in the studio
and you know i'm working with
professional engineers and professional
musicians and i'm learning i'm really
learning how to do all these things that
are going to come in play later on and
then the third one like i said they
found a little homemade tape i made and
they manufactured it later on after i
got signed to jive oh damn okay we got a
little secret weapon but you know i
never had a problem with 75 girls
because for one we never we never had an
agreement we never had a written
agreement
two
dean hodges taught me detail how to run
a independent label every step from a to
z
and then
third you know
you taught me how to be a player
so
not only was i you know working with
these professional musicians in a
professional studio you know we had
endless weed it was like [ __ ] like
like
like cocaine was free everything was
just free just make music and be in the
environment
and
i learned a lot so right i never had any
problem with 75 girls because when i
look back it was i was like earning a
master's degree
sure being a [ __ ] player and a rapper
and whatever
what i think is really interesting too
is that uh you know
coming out of la there there was like
like the hip-hop was like heavily
influenced by gang culture
but they didn't really have gang culture
in oakland so much as just hustlers and
pimps
let me tell you something that every
single hustler and every single pimp
knows that is that you have to smell
good man and i like to feel good about
smelling good and that's why i use
native deodorant because they don't test
on animals it's totally vegan they only
use ingredients that you've heard of man
that you know are good for you and it
works so well man i love to use it plus
guess what they've got special holiday
scents just for the holidays candy cane
sugar cookie fresh mistletoe i'm telling
you there's a scent for everybody with
this company and i love them plus if you
go to nativedeodorand.com
and use the promo code stevo you get 20
off your first order and like i said man
this company they're good people they do
the right thing they don't harm animals
they only use quality ingredients that
are good for you there's no aluminum i
just love them and i want you to support
them i want you to smell good and feel
good so one more time go to
nativedeodorant.com
and use the promo code stevo for 20
off your order and to feel good about
smelling good and supporting good people
yeah dude now let's talk about hustlers
and pimps
and even the gang gangs that are that
are in the bay they don't
they don't gang bang because of blue and
red
and territory and it's not some some of
it could be neighborhood others could be
uh we're we're born
bound together by money and the hustle
or like-minded things but it's not it's
not open and shut rules of you're blue
and red we're enemies it was it was
never like that yeah different kind of
gang bang up there it's just different
gang
if you had to analyze it and you were
like law enforcement you go it's no
different but in the streets it's a lot
it's different than
walking around going oh my god let's get
to doing red you know right right a lot
different that's a lot different yeah
and and so
like
you were basically like the first
mixtape cat right like
there was no name for it yeah there's no
name for it and you had just audio
cassettes
and and what was like the first time
that you went out to sell them you sold
them like to a drug dealer the very
first tape we ever sold i had a rap
partner his name was freddie b
he was rapping in his world
you know he had been like you know
juvenile correctional facilities and
getting in trouble and stuff and he knew
lots of people all over the city from
you know he grew up in west oakland
lived in east oakland he just knew a lot
of people and
i was really popular from like 1981 82
like from being around the city riding
on the buses and um
having my big radio and letting people
hear my raps what we got here with some
burritos man
i'm super popular right but now i got
these guys coming like yeah man you know
my boy freddy b he raps he's better than
you he's you know so what they were
really doing was in the spirit of hip
hop early 80s they're like let's get a
battle rap going with the only two
rappers we know so they they put us to
rap against each other and we did
and as i hear a lot of rappers who
became really good friends say they
first battled and they became friends we
became friends okay so
we recorded some stuff at his house
and it was cool and i was like dude you
should come by my house because i had
like this quality equipment where you
could record and you'd sound really good
because i knew how to set the levels and
i had the right microphones and little
effects machines and when he heard what
we sounded like after recording in my
house he said
we should sell this or we could sell
this something like that and i'm like
sell it to who he's like [ __ ] some drug
dealers right down the street right like
[ __ ] let's go so so that was the first
tape you sold was to the drug dealers
you just walked up to him and popped it
in one guy had a car with a nice little
sound system and we said hey you guys
want to buy rap tape and they were like
what the [ __ ] for like why and you know
freddie b's like just listen to it so
they listen and we're just sitting there
kicking it listening one tape
and a guy walks up to the radio he leans
in the car and presses eject
and says i'll buy it so when he said
that like how much five dollars somebody
else said let me get one we're like we
only got one but we'll be back tomorrow
dude that's epic and then and so check
this out i don't know if you guys know
this but
too short selling like a tape before it
was called a mixtape for five bucks but
then and he's selling to drug dealers so
like people who are like kind of like
bosses and and players and hustlers like
you know people within money guys yeah
money people in oakland they start
making like requests hey man you're
selling these tapes i want you to custom
make me a tape where you shout me up
like like work me into a rap song so he
starts custom making rap songs for like
bosses in oakland and he's selling those
tapes for 20 bucks
it's like the original cameo almost i
did it
that was an accident too that wasn't on
purpose we kind of were trying to
win over this one guy we were we were we
were working with one of his drug dealer
workers one of his lower level guys
and he was bringing us over there
because he had some really good
equipment he wanted to be a rapper
and he's like bringing us to his spot
but at his spot there's this [ __ ]
drugs being sold yeah and one of the big
boss guys the actual big boss guy is
walking around with this mean face and
you know just not saying anything to us
so we you know this kind of guy you like
hey what's up man he just don't say [ __ ]
back to you that kind of [ __ ] so
we asked him one day we like
hey you won't want our tapes we're gonna
give it to him for free and he just like
lit into us with a he's like i don't
give a [ __ ] about rap music [ __ ] that
rap [ __ ] like why would i leave like why
would i listen to rap if it's about
somebody else if it was about me i
listened to it like ah okay so we like
[ __ ] like we got cussed the [ __ ] out by
the boss man like some scary [ __ ] we
like we leave and go man we gotta make a
tape about him like yeah like it's
mandatory so we bring him back to check
we just go here and walk away just hear
it just give it to him just don't ask
nothing ever it's absolutely [ __ ]
genius because that gets you in with the
most influential people so look at this
he never says thank you he never says i
liked it he never said i listened to it
he never said [ __ ]
and this other guy comes walking up to
us out the blue one day we're on the
streets walking down the street and this
guy's like
like yelling he's like do you know where
the [ __ ] you at and do you know who the
[ __ ] i am he's like if you [ __ ]
don't get me a tape like you made him
i better not ever see you out here ever
again
later day later we're like here you go
he was the one who when we handed him
the tape he just gave us 20 bucks like
here okay he's like y'all cool y'all
cool so
we so then people that's two people that
had custom-made tapes now the request
started coming in which is why we named
them the special request because we
started getting like summons like so
when so when you make a special request
are you like like writing an entire song
from scratch are you just re-recording
styling so i end up with this little pad
like you know this size little little
pocket pad i got a pin on me or
something and i'm i'm like taking notes
uh the guys on 84th one five tapes like
you know and just keep it like
come back and get the money and so
somebody pull up on us we like sitting
on the bus stop and like a little nice
little car pull up and go hey you guys
are too short freddie b you're like yeah
like get in the car
like okay
and we go drive to some little exclusive
neighborhood where you can't get past
the goons unless you they let you pass
and then we go back and we meet the boss
he's like yeah i want to get one of
those tapes
like okay what you want your tape to say
he's like yeah talk about my car and my
block and you know name a couple of my
homies and
i'm taking notes i'm like oh my god it's
amazing all this is going in the tape
and we come back and it turned into a
really
popular thing that
like just the only the bosses wanted to
spend the 20 bucks i could spend the 20
bucks it's so [ __ ] funny and i've
never heard none of that none of the
little guys really wanted it that's like
like right
[ __ ] dude but this is in the 80s right i
mean 20 bucks
82 83 right how many bosses did you make
it for
the whole city
everybody got their own legit original
track you people were riding around
listening a song about themselves
sick yeah i mean i've never heard that
like you've got to be the only guy who
came up that way and then and then
presumably because these people are big
bosses then now
like when they've got they've got you
doing live gigs and so we did we also dj
the the
the hood parties the parties that
you know it'd be like in somebody's
living room
uh you know just just
whatever like in a [ __ ] apartment
little tiny ass apartment crammed with
people whatever it may be and
at those parties we did a lot of
personal stuff too like we'd really be
naming people in the crowd saying you
know we kind of like that was what they
were doing in new york in the bronx we
like let's do our version of it so you
walk in the party you somebody you get
your name said you know we might put you
put you in like some rhyming words or
something and everybody just loved us so
who's putting on these parties
uh we were on this i guess like house
party circuit where
um i guess you could relate them to like
what people might call like a rent party
in the projects where you know one
family's trying to raise some money in
the night just to you know so it could
just be some kids or some young people
trying to make some money so it's a
really low investment you buy a few
bottles of liquor
you um you pass out some little index
cards with invites and [ __ ] you only
need a few hundred people and basically
the formula was um you pass out these
little flyers and go come to house party
on 92nd avenue here's the address is
from
11 p.m to 3 a.m and it's a dollar to get
in the door and a dollar for a drink
something like that all right
and it's affordable for the party going
person they pay me about 100 bucks 50
bucks whatever 75 bucks and we do take
your party we rap at the [ __ ] and i
found out
all these things that i was doing were
forms of marketing that you would want
young artists to do so the first time
they ever asked me to stand in front of
a crowd of thousands of people
a friend of mine lionel b he worked for
bill graham
uh you know bill graham did all the big
concerts uh
the grateful dead all this stuff yeah
legendary promoter yeah bill graham had
a a side company called barrier
productions that he did a lot of a lot
of urban concerts with so they asked me
if i wanted to be the opening act on one
of the shows
it was when that song um it was utfo
roxanne roxanne
okay oh [ __ ] 1985
and
um
they asked me to open the show i never
had made a record never been in the
studio
just tapes only and i went out there in
front of 5 000 6 000 people
and everybody in the crowd knew every
word everything i was saying yeah that's
that's
i get off stage i didn't even know it
was gonna happen i get off stage and
come back and people were like who the
[ __ ] are you like right how the [ __ ] do
they know your [ __ ] you never made a
record
like i don't know man
and then there's another like people
like
pretty
notable thing
is that rap music in the early 80s was
just so clean you know i mean i i what
comes to mind for me is the song white
lines where it's just like it's say no
to drugs like kind of thing you know the
fat boys run dmc like they didn't they
didn't have like gangsters explicit
lyrics right explicit lyrics and then
here you come along 1982 19
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah straight up
and uh
and you just were unapologetic about
just being like so you really were like
the first
like hardcore
like explicit rapper talking about
[ __ ] and and yeah when you get like
uh
you know
the late 80s and you got groups like nwa
emerging
i'm right there with them
but i had a like a head start
on the genre already sure when
ice t made six in the morning i mean
that was like the floodgates opening to
to you know graphic rhyming rhymes that
come from the west coast and you know
with the west you know it's graphic like
the message what's the six in the
morning from ice tea was that something
he did on his own
that was his rendition of um schooly
diesel uh
parkside killers whatever it was
and it's um
it's just a it's just a tale of like a
day in a gangbanger's life right no i
asked that because i'm i'm just
wondering if that's like
you know after he left nwa no iced tea
not ice cream iced tea
before ice tea oh [ __ ]
makes this movie shows up in the movie
breaking yeah you're right you're right
right and he's making records before us
like dr dre was in it kind of early as a
world-class record crew but
um
i was on the explicit [ __ ] when they
were all doing that egyptian lover is
you know being sure he's doing these
hyper sex songs but they're not really
explicit lyrics they're just explicit
content
but i'm in oakland and i'm like [ __ ]
suck my dick like literally right and
when they finally when they finally got
me on the stage which i come at the same
time as eric being rock kim and public
enemy you know at 87 88 89 but i'm
already like seasoned i've already been
in front of
hundreds of crowds i've done so many
house parties with the most ruthless
gangsters that
like basically you better be good or you
might get beat up type [ __ ] so
so you go from 75 girls and then you got
your own thing is uh is dangerous
dangerous music is just a carbon copy of
what 75 girls except it's your [ __ ]
except we own it now right we don't we
don't just work for the big brother and
how long does the the dangerous thing go
it gets us all the way to
uh jive records
and everybody who started dangerous
music with me
i think it was around we started it in
like um
87. okay so 75 girls is like 85 86 87.
somewhere in the middle of 87 we switch
over and we go down and we start our own
company we call it dangerous music and
we put our freaky tails and we get the
money now right
and then now like 1989
now you're doing a little strange
[ __ ] big deal everything's big arena
tour with nwa yeah that [ __ ]
an arena tour with nwa is a very big
deal and you know i made a very big deal
out of something recently which was to
try to set a world record for doing the
highest belly flop ever done into pure
pee you know what happened when we
collected
over 190 gallons of prp
it just turned out that that p was way
too dark you know why because i was
dehydrated man it turns out like two out
of three americans experience
dehydration on a regular basis some
crazy statistics man and i'm one of them
so i've been taking hydration super
seriously and i finally found the ticket
man it's called liquid iv
and
this stuff is absolutely delicious has
less sugar than one apple and by pouring
one of your little stick packets into 16
ounces of water and pounding it you get
way more hydrated than if you had just
drank that water alone these people are
on top of the science man and
honestly i just like it because it's so
darn delicious but i'm also very
concerned about staying hydrated so it's
one stop shopping with liquid iv
and speaking of shopping if you go to
liquidive.com and use the promo code
stevo they're giving 25
off the orders people from the wild ride
podcast man
i love this company i love this product
and i love taking care of myself and
being a healthy guy so join me okay get
on over to liquidive.com use the promo
code stevo to enjoy
off your order plus waiting to get a
load of all the flavors passion fruit
lemon lime
like guava i'm telling you
stay hydrated with me and let's talk
about nwa arena tours
so that was in arenas yeah that's the
first time i went out it was the
straight out of the compton tour first
time straight out of secure the opening
act for nwa actually i was the guy easy
easy he called me he's the leader of
enjoy
he called me and said hey you want to go
on tour like hell yeah and
i was the act that went on right before
nwa sure so it was a lot of opening
nights oh got you okay we merged tours
with ellen
you're the the co-main event we merged
tours with ll cool j for about two weeks
so they were like co-headlining
and that's not a match and that tour
came along with like
salt and pepper and daylight song and
kid and play and
and you know these guys everybody's got
hot records but if i get you like
somewhere deep down south or somewhere
in some little town in in michigan
somewhere you ain't [ __ ] with me and
i'm a lot i was i was out there
murdering groups like murdering like i
dare you to come on stage after me
because if you if even to this day if
you come on after me you have to be of
that cloth of
the crowd loves me they love my music
i'm good like like i know a lot of
groups i can go on before and after me
and we give them like the one two three
and the crowd's having the best night of
their life but if you dare like don't do
what i do to a crowd and you come on
after me it really shows
what you can't do like you're going
before me they love you i come on it
turns up and they don't notice it but if
you come out after me you better be one
of those guys
yeah so the nwa did pretty good after
you oh of course i mean they had this
they had all the [ __ ] you know crowd
participation they had all the drama in
the show they brought the stage set yeah
they had the [ __ ] crazy explicit [ __ ]
no they could go from like like they
used to come on like uh ren and dre
would do a little
get everybody hyped and do a couple
songs then ice cube would come out and
do about 10 15 minutes by yourself and
then they build up to this whole thing
where you finally get to see easy and
they all see all these [ __ ] songs it
was it was amazing like
fun after parties
they did a pretty good rendition of what
that show was like
in the movie straight out of the car oh
cool man it was a lot of people a lot of
us who were
watching the movie like you know people
you know people who are tough people who
are close to stories like that how it
happened right
it was tough to get right i was standing
there that day i know it really happened
so it was it was that type of situation
and and i heard that when you were on
tour with nwa in 1989 that they had like
protests
outside the arena like like
that actually succeeded in shutting
shows down yeah it was a lot of threats
if you sing those explicit songs you're
going to jail
it was um i remember one show i wanted i
feel like
i don't even want to say where we were
but we were somewhere it could be like
northwest
somewhere
and
it was so serious the show was sold out
and it was so serious with the parents
yeah the parents were protesting and it
was one of those towns where you can't
go against your parents you can't you
just you can't
and literally the tickets were sold out
and the crowd was empty because on the
day of the show
the community protested the venue they
they came out and picketed the venue and
the kids couldn't cross the picket lines
with their own show was actually
cancelled no it wouldn't cancel we
performed to an empty crowd to a light
crowd you got all the money
yeah
i remember doing shows back then like
[ __ ] like tulsa oklahoma and
the crowd being given strict
instructions that no one stands up no
one
uh like you can't like get all into the
show like emotion
when the song ends you could clap
so
it was very strange but you know for the
most part we were out there walling now
it was damn did you ever have like any
sort of a legal case for like a free
speech thing or did anything like that
ever come out i've ran from the cops a
couple times after a show i've um
i've been arrested a couple times like
columbus georgia arrested everybody they
arrested here what was it um like two
live crew the uh
felony obscenity yeah yeah you just you
know i got that charge i beat it too
yeah they tell you at least it's a
little fine or whatever you can fight
whatever but they tell you before you go
on they posted on the dressing room they
tell you you cannot say these words you
can't
do this illegal in this city to say
these words in front of a crowd yeah and
as soon as you say they always let me do
the whole show and then get arrested
right on the side of the stage i did
like there's it's it's american heroes
who have caught that obscenity charge
you got jim morrison two live crew lenny
bruce prince
prince too short ll cool j stevo
yeah and dude i i respect the
coming up on selling the cassette tapes
man because
like you know i came up way later but
still i came up at a time where
for me to make my noise and get my
recognition like i had to record video
cassettes you know i hit play on one vcr
and record on the other and i'm
duplicating my tapes i'm taking them to
the post office
and so yeah i was kind of in the mix
mixtape game too man exactly i mean you
gotta you have to adapt to your
environment
to become popular like
you're really good at what you do
because you do it a lot
whole the other 10 000 hour theory
to become an expert at something but you
know you're really good but you know we
know people who are better than us who
never make it as far as we do sure they
were missing that that drive of right
the hustle the self the self marketing
and stuff like that right i've been
thinking about this a lot lately and
what i've arrived at is that to become
successful
it's helpful to be intelligent
it's not not mandatory it's helpful to
have discipline
but
nothing is more important than
enthusiasm enthusiasm is the driver of
all things that [ __ ] matter you know
when people ask me how do i do this man
i want to get into this like think of
the advice
i say the same thing i don't give a [ __ ]
what it is you want to do the only thing
that matters is how bad you want to do
it and it's like when you when you're
[ __ ] you've got your mind made up and
you're enthusiastic and you're just
[ __ ] driven
that's when [ __ ] happens too
yeah i remember i was um i was truly in
love with
a woman who i thought was the most
beautiful woman on the planet i was in
love
and
one day she said with the most serious
face this was probably
i have like 20 plus albums this was
probably when i was on like album number
four or five
and she's like
well you know now that we're in love and
we're together you know you can't sing
those explicit songs anymore
i was like
we had to break up
because of my love for what i did and i
i think back on that when you think back
and go damn what if i'd stopped the too
short style at album yeah dude
what would my life have been if i turned
the corner if you got [ __ ] whipped
that's rule number one how to be a
player right
that's that's that's like you know some
99 problems [ __ ] dude yeah
when you're in this business i mean
things like that
like you got to go just shy of [ __ ]
whipping like you right when you notice
the whipping you got to run that whip
comes out dude i'm i'm
you gotta run i'm dead i mean where's
she
it comes in like you can't hang around
your friends anymore like things that
are making you you that she got you for
right
she's right [ __ ] no more so she so when
you're uh your easy e reaches out to you
and brings you on tour and that's just
[ __ ] that's massive man i mean right
that's where like it's no longer an
oakland thing yeah that's where i'm like
selling 300 000 records and i go on tour
and the tour ends and i'm at 800 000.
and then you know shortly after that it
goes to 1.3 million it's like selling
500 000 in chunks just because of that
height of
of what we did you know right your
parents were both accountants right my
parents were college graduate
accountants and they wanted nothing to
do with their child being a rapper
and like you said it takes a certain
amount of intelligence it helps yeah and
it really does it's like you know
your parents say [ __ ] like you're not
wasting that brain like i'm not i just
adjusted it to do this other new thing
that you don't really know about yet
you'll catch on but how much did their
career like stick in your head about
like money consciousness when the money
started rolling in uh were you good at
it like keeping track or were you just
like i just had the smarts to never
let anyone else be in charge of the
business or the money
so i was like
you could be my partner and we can look
at these things together but you can't
be the one who looks at the numbers and
brings it in and then tell me where my
right nobody could ever be that and i
saw a lot of my peers
have that person in their life and that
was their downfall but you were like
looking at the reports and like you were
good at that [ __ ] thing everything had
to go through my name had to be on
everything
like you could work for me but i
couldn't work for you
and then you know there's times where
you're switching camps and then once you
switch the camp the old camp
that they got some kind of problem they
feel like all the money you're making
now is their money so even if you're in
charge and you're looking at all the
numbers that you're still smart enough
at a young age though to like at the end
of those
those
partnerships and just like i'll buy
everybody out yeah like how much you
want to go away here you go and instead
of the fight for life so when you buy
them out
you can still be friends you know so you
want the snoop route instead of the dre
route
well drake is something that i don't
think anybody would do he just walked
away he walked away and then he didn't
take anything with him he started over
from scratch he literally
legally
was like what 25 percent owner of what
he walked away from right and it was
worth
400 million right and all that and how
many how many of those hundreds of
millions were just disappeared with
everybody in jail or dead it was it was
like it appears to be like some kind of
bad money or something like it was it's
crazy how much money just it's crazy how
many people ran away from it yeah
and they walked away ran away then just
like just go like they just left yeah
walked away but then master p bought
snoops
it's his exit when you talk to him he
says that um
that exit from
death row and that time he had on
no limit with master p
saved his life absolutely he didn't have
a way out he didn't really have the
the
business sense to get out
showed him this is what you're worth
this is what you can do and the master p
brought him to atlanta right like and
and
he master p i i feel like he was doing a
lot out of new orleans yeah i think
louisiana okay yeah all right and i
think snoop says he wouldn't got a house
in new orleans or houston right right
right i think it was louisiana somewhere
down there and he just kind of got him
out of his element and they bought out
the contract and a lot of what snoop and
the dog pound were doing when they
became death row artists was
what things they picked up on that
journey down south through masterpiece
it was it was um
it was um no let me get it right they
were down south before death row
and then
they did their death row thing and went
back oh [ __ ] okay
they went down south in houston and
messing around
you know before they signed the
difference right that makes sense yeah
let me get it right yeah i remember
that's just so i mean it's still the
same idea you know you're gonna you're
gonna like end a partnership you buy
them out and when you do that is it like
you got lawyers like with contracts to
make it like tight or is it just like
hey man be cool here's some money it's a
little bit of both okay you gotta like
you gotta have some kind of man-to-man
and then you gotta
have some kind of legal yeah contract
to dissolve it but
yeah like uh and then i guess some
people don't really give too much of a
[ __ ] you know i just i just try to avoid
the fallout
that turns into a war right because
you know it
that's that's a waste of time man so
it's a waste of time and then looking
back i saw a lot of careers end
through those little in inner circle
fields feuds
like you just picked a few people over
at the assigned to a major label and one
album doesn't go right and you hate
three people over there and you go to
war with and you're just [ __ ] in your
career
dude i i brought this up with be real
how i watched this uh hulu documentary
about tekashi69
and like that's a prime example of where
like
he and it wasn't even with the label or
anything it was just like he's got five
like like hits on the billboard 100 all
at the same time he's got money coming
in but he just decides to switch his
loyalty from
like one crew to another crew and
they're like watching all this money
come in he's like
like that's asking for trouble
and somehow he's still doing good you
know he's
he's actually probably killing it right
now yeah it really is
yeah i don't know man
like i don't have an opinion either way
you know like it's not my place to have
an opinion but i was fascinated by that
documentary man i thought i thought it
was [ __ ]
truly interesting
yeah he um he played with fire yeah too
he did yeah and then i think that he's
still like probably playing with it but
um
back to the nwa tour like easy reaches
out to did you ever lay down a track
with easy
rappers didn't make songs together back
then different crews didn't you didn't
mix the crew like your crew
had your djs your crew had your rappers
you had your beat makers and that's you
guys did that for yourself and then and
then run dmc changed the [ __ ] by doing
the walk this way with aerosmith yeah
but that was also a collab that was
clearly different it was rick rubin
right it was in rick rubin's mind and he
always wanted to infuse rock and roll
ahead of sounding rock with rap and he
did it and it was big and he knew he was
right what he was hearing but
it's still
what they were doing back then if you
weren't under
russell rush management or assigned to
dev jam you weren't really getting right
rick rubin russell simmons influence
yeah and it's probably a pretty big deal
too
just the fact that easy e reaches out to
you to bring you on tour like that's
probably another thing that
you know he just knew that he was
looking at the numbers he knew how
popular i was
in the cities that we were going to and
he's like
you know we had to at one point before i
dropped the alamo toured on his life was
too short and they were touring on
straight out of compton right before
that he had
boys in the hood the song out which was
like yeah easy does it yeah like a super
giant record of like summer like 87 88
like the songs that just don't go away i
had freaky chills out those two records
freaky tails and boys in the hood were
like
they're like the best two records you
could listen to in your car if you had
woofers
and
um i mean we just had that neck and neck
thing we were doing where we did smaller
shows together and he saw the reaction
to the crowd and he just was like i
guess he had the opportunity to headline
a tour and he's like i'm gonna take this
guy to show with me we didn't really
know know each other we just knew each
other from backstage and what's up and
you know and what was your label at that
time you said drive records i was on
dangerous music but i just signed a job
i owned dangerous music and i just
signed a job so what's the motivation
for that like if you own the label that
you're on like what can drive drive can
offer you distribution distribution
distribution worldwide distribution we
were limited to
we were making a lot of money but we
were limited to how fast we could
manufacture the product oh wow and then
get it to
the streets
and then
right keep it in stores we we kept
selling out we could never
manufacture enough that's a good problem
to have and when you do negotiate that
deal with jive presumably because you've
got your own label and you're in pretty
good shape owning your own [ __ ] that
gives you leverage to negotiate a better
deal with jive to a certain extent yeah
the labels are
masters of
you know just right pimping exactly
because it's catchy how tough you get
you still turn around five years later
and go this [ __ ] shitty ass deal
right especially because like
you know
we're talking about a time when it was
impossible to really break out as a
mainstream star
with like with like global success
without a record deal but it was
impossible to really make money without
owning your own music so it's like
chicken
like you know you don't think of it when
you're 20 21 years old but
like logically like what does it why
does it take 50 pages of a
artist contract and 50 pages of a
publishing contract to make a deal with
you why what does 50 [ __ ] pages do
and
i mean literally in these contracts
literally
you could have the best deal from page
one to twelve
and [ __ ] page 36 in one paragraph
says everything we agreed to
on one through twelve yeah ain't true
that's right and they're like well you
should've told them to take out this
paragraph i [ __ ] i knew it just says
where to wherefore whereas in one
sentence right right yeah you need a
lawyer to look over the contract to sign
your own lawyer
exactly so i don't know about that
but uh but did you did you have uh
you really you really learned that i
needed i need a lawyer right now i need
a lawyer to lawyer on my lawyer well
yeah it's like if you sign a lawyer on
they're like okay cool like just sign
this contract with us you're like that's
what i'm hiring you for right
yeah what the [ __ ]
when you signed a drive in uh like what
like 89 or before it was 88 88 okay and
at that point do you have a lawyer
negotiating your deal with jive we had
we had lawyers and everything but at the
same time we were
we were at a point where we couldn't
really
we didn't we didn't want to become that
company that like we should have like if
you think about what it could have been
how it could have been a million dollars
we could have been that that's a lot of
[ __ ] work sure and you know i'm a
music guy i didn't i didn't want to get
tied up with the being a manufacturer in
the adventures
where was the jive deal
it was a seven
seven album deal yeah probably seven
hours the first that's a lot
that's a lot of albums probably six
because we came in with one okay but
and then we gave him the second one
really fast so it wasn't really yeah
right like i heard that you
delivered all your albums before you
even received the budget yeah just turn
the albums in and you know we got
through the contract pretty quick and
then we renegotiated for like like a
really decent look but and how many how
many albums on the renegotiation deal
probably another handful i ended up at
jive with like 12 13 albums somewhere
over there right but
um
how many did you think that dangerous
uh before drive yeah we dangerous we
just did the one out i'm born in the mac
okay so three on seven
we signed a lot of groups through jive
and a couple other labels oh so you did
the the whole like uh interscope and and
shady it's kind of exactly you kind of
like the sub label whatever they call it
right so
you gotta put the [ __ ] in context though
because
i'm doing good i'm regional very strong
west coast right you know little
tentacles out beyond the west coast but
i'm making most of my money from
san diego to seattle and just it's west
coast and this it's the distribution
people that i'm using out of the bay
they don't they can't really give you a
new yorker anywhere unless they
partner with another distribution so we
we know we knew our limitations and then
we looking at jive records who
approached us and at the time
they had the hottest rapper
kumo d
they had
they just signed a boogie down
productions krs-1
just signed jazzy jeff and the fresh
prince will smith
and
they hadn't got tribe called quest yet
but they had um houdini
houdini was next to run dmc you had me
at cairo
yeah but i'm saying they had houdini
this is before krs yeah this houdini is
huge they're the group that comes on the
show with run dmc and everybody and they
steal the show that's those guys
and their own job they have [ __ ]
billy ocean caribbean queen
wow and it's like they're doing big
things but they to me
i'm looking
at um
kumodi
and i'm looking at
um
uh houdini and i'm like well [ __ ] that's
big right okay and and you're right like
they're gonna give you all the
the
promotion all they're gonna they're
gonna blow you up it's kind of like me
being stand-up comedy like i do i do
comedy and my uh my last comedy special
i put it out on my own website did great
with it but that's like independently
putting it out now like what's what's
going to be the effect on my future
career if i put my next special out on
netflix that's probably pretty similar
so yeah man it's just um it was just a
matter of distribution and then on the
other end
you probably
the percentages in the deal
don't allow you to get what you get when
you're independent but then that's a
trade-off for
traveling around the world and getting
paid a lot of money to perform in arenas
and then you get
i don't get this career
i don't think i get the career that i
have i've had if i stay independent
right i get sort of like you know who
stayed independent as far as cash 20
millionaires they
ended up with um they ended up with
universal
cash money early on they got this one
remember the 5 million deal and they got
the five million and it was okay you
know it was juvenile back that ass up
and all that they they went big
um i'm talking about more like a guy
like sir mix a lot okay
who did really good in like real estate
and he you know he did really good with
his independent label and he decided to
be his own mogul up in seattle without
becoming
what the rest of us did which was you
know
trading your independent hustle for
how about master p did he ever signed
her a label i really feel like he went
to priority which was like not a major
major but he went to priority and hooked
up a deal where
he hooked up a deal where he could
make a lot of money would
major distribution
but independent type of so it kind of
split the numbers yeah exactly
and that's what um a lot of people did
that over at priority
yeah i think um you know master p he
really
i think the smartest thing he did was to
the body about a movie and he did the
movie the same way he did
the independent distribution of the
music so these really cheesy ass movies
made a lot of profit yeah so from there
you couldn't really hold him back
anymore and you know everybody makes a
little chest move that gets you to the
next level sure
so so people didn't collab on tracks
um together back in the day it really
didn't unless you were claiming to be
this you know
uh
affiliated crews or something
it was i could hang around rappers all
day we would never say let's do a song
together it would never come up right
okay that'd be like let's get in the hot
tub together this is like weird
um
but uh but boy did you
like end up
doing tracks with a bunch of people man
you made one with tupac the reason why i
started doing a lot of collaborations is
because
in 1996
i turned 30 years old
at that time
there was a myth that 30 year old
rappers were old as [ __ ] right and
when i turned 30 i released my 10th
album
and 10 albums was like who's got 10
albums like that like out of rappers
in 1996 nobody had 10 albums so
when i announced that i was 30 years old
i released my 10th album and i'm
stepping away from the rap game i
retired they were like oh [ __ ] and then
they checked the track record and of
those 10 albums it was like six platinum
and like four gold some [ __ ] like that
some some some crazy
number and then the rumor went out too
short i got ten platinum albums and it's
like all good for pr
but
the numbers i always play on the numbers
being the accountant's child yeah and
i'm like okay the 30 the 10 nice round
numbers you know i retired and when i
retired i got all this free press it's
the most free press i ever got
that was positive
and
because you know negative press is free
as [ __ ] yeah and that [ __ ] goes far
but you know this best
free
press i ever got
that was you know
in in my favor and it was like two short
retired two show retires ten platinum
house blah blah blah and it just went
everywhere i just held one little press
conference and i threw a retirement
party at the century club in uh beverly
hills in central city whatever and
it was just it just the work
my phone went crazy and people were like
well if you're gonna retire let me get a
verse let's get on my album do this now
so i did a song with jay-z
yeah prior to the retirement i've worked
with um you know some key figures uh i
saw tupac yeah tupac came and got on one
of my albums and i did some stuff with
tupac with aunt banks who's my guy
um
i did this song with biggie yeah the
world is filled so now i already got the
jay-z thing happen
happening i did a song with eric sermon
uh me and him did a duet called buy you
some
and
you know he was huge in new york so
these records come out by you some
i did a song with little kim call me on
the
booty call movie soundtrack i do the
biggie song the world is filled and then
i had the jay-z song real [ __ ] do real
things whatever so this is my little
retirement party that's here
so i retire and then because it's biggie
jay-z you know they
everybody start constantly man let me
get a two-shirt first two shirt first so
i really went on like a
from that point on i just did like a
million features
and
you know it just turned into
kevin bacon seven degrees of separation
you know yeah like [ __ ]
bacon
that's i rap with everybody in it and
you know the east coast west coast thing
broke out and
i was so wedged into
loyal friendship with everybody that was
supposed to be enemies in the war that
when they
they they came to me and they said pick
a side and i was like it ain't my war
like i'm i'm from oakland that's great
man i do what do you see say about it
like uh
when you know i've brought up how eminem
and snoop are going after each other he
says hey man i'm switzerland
diplomatic yeah yeah so do we have to
cut this short i don't mean to be rude
do we because
we pushed your thing back and do you
have a premiere at six oh yeah i hate to
be that guy but
i see a lot of people huddling around
the car looking in so i'm not sure if
those points got randolph i'm playing
livestock
i mean i hate to be the the web blanket
we can
yeah two guys just showed up yeah
they're getting the mic from the surfing
thing and yeah i think we're getting
ready
with you because there's another dude
looking in to see what we got the light
all right man what dude
what what a pleasure man sorry to cut
everybody off
this has been going fantastic we can
edit around we can edit around it i
gotta tell you man i i
like have had my struggles
with
like not shutting the [ __ ] up with not
with like talking over people and uh and
and i think that this one
i think this one went really well dude
yeah you know
if i still [ __ ] up a little bit but
not as much as usual
if steve
brings back his rap career would you
ever sing a verse on one of his albums
depends on the song okay yeah i'm making
a song about uh
it's called i love my girl
but
that's right i'm too short to alley
right i'm already on that um
i did a song with uh one of those guys
the lonely island and lonely yeah oh my
god
[Music]
i love my girl but except it's about
that one week a month man she the
[ __ ] the demon shows up man i can't
[ __ ] with the demon
i'm like i love my girl but i love my
other girl too
yeah oh hey man dude it's been a
pleasure dude really thank you so
much sorry i was late too man that that
was a bad look and and thank you for
being cool about it
dope
what can we shout out for you
uh just make sure you let the world know
about mount westmore mount westmore is
too short e40 ice cube and snoop dogg we
just started a group we just released
wow
we released a single called big sub
woofer
and
the album's coming out and you and you
think okay those guys got together and
made an album no we actually got
together and recorded 50 songs
and
we put an album together and it was
really difficult to figure out
which songs could make the first album
that's a power group mount westmore yeah
i guarantee not westmore too short ice
cube e40 and snoop yeah look it up right
now it's everywhere
i'll say that in the intro to the
podcast so that's the first piece of
info they get all right man hey man
yeah dude how sweet was that
now you know i love you you guys who
stick around at the very end and i want
to tell you something um
i've been
resistant to playing back the podcasts
and studying them even though i know
that that's gonna make me better at it
but now i've stumbled on a new
uh
practice
yeah dude we set the youtube version of
the podcast to premiere and then when it
premieres i go in the live chat which
forces me to review the podcast so i can
study it and get better and it allows me
to interact with you guys in real time
because i'm seeing every single one of
your comments and i'm responding to you
guys so yeah dude it's a lot of fun man
now it's a big deal it's the premiere
of the wild ride podcast on the youtube
version so i'm excited
excited about that [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
thanks dudes
[Music]